foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
what's up guys
what's going on Dirk will be here
momentarily well then just launched a
little early you know um first off this
is the new time 5 30. the reason we're
going at 5 30 is because I I do feel
like dirt
was doing a little too much like he
would literally come home from work and
come straight into the show
so
me being you know is is
easy as I can on on my co-host I was
like look man
take you 30 minutes get get get going
and then we'll we'll start the show you
don't gotta come straight off the
streets to to the podcast man you don't
got to come straight off the streets to
the podcast
so 5 30 that way you know when he gets
home because he was literally coming
home
and pretty much going straight to his
computer every week
your boy didn't know that
your boy had to change that
I ain't trying to be
issues with people man I I'm trying to
elevate
not push people down
so that that's why we're doing at 5 30
now 30 minutes you know I think I'll
probably pop in occasionally
pop in occasionally to uh
do a little bit of like a kind of like a
fun pre-show but that that's the new
thing you know we we go in to make sure
dirt's taken care of he needs that he
needs that 30 minutes to himself man I'm
a lot to handle as it is so I can't
imagine how he was handling like the
moment he got off work
what's going on Dirk
how do I sound you sound perfect
cool
so we got a lot we got a lot to talk
about today Dirk I'm sure yeah man
you've seen the the red fall stuff
of course of course I am you're
definitely going to talk about that so
let's let's go and get on
what's going on you guys appreciate it
for coming through the attitude we
talked about the past present future
again we got my calls with me Dirk
Gregory what's going on dirt griggity
what is up everybody
let's go man yeah so today we we have a
pretty Lively show for you guys you know
we got a little sprinkle a little bit of
funness we got PlayStation can't survive
without Cod
that's not my worst that's Day words we
got Joseph Staton leaving Xbox and
Microsoft in general after he did his
you know Halo infinite jump out of the
company to another company thing and we
got a red fog coming in hard at 30
frames a second uh so first uh
yeah so so first thing we're going to
talk about is what you've been playing
there you know we we I don't care some
people literally don't like us talking
about what we've been playing to this
day I don't understand to this day I
don't understand
yeah
what I recently trained this recipe
before we make loved it you know I
mentioned before how I never did finish
the original one on PS2 like once it
came to the PS2 never finished it loved
it uh it's a great game um but I
recently just started ghostwire Tokyo so
I'm right at the beginning so yeah I
just started that one but that's about
it bro yeah here you go Ghost Rider
Tokyo I still ain't really jumped into
it now
um
I don't think it's a bad game uh but
what I've seen in like the
infrastructure of the game doesn't seem
like something that I would enjoy uh but
what I can say is I really enjoyed Hi-Fi
Rush uh so just to success of HiFi rush
and how much I enjoyed that makes me
even want to go back and try something
uh is different is Ghost Rider turkey or
even though that I look at that nothing
about ghost bar Tokyo is appealing to me
um the success that they had because I
liked evil with them but I didn't beat
either one of them yeah I love both of
them but I did like the games I like the
concept of the games I think that's the
reason like Ghost Rider like disconnects
from me a little bit is because I want
Xbox to have their own Resident Evil
vein you know what I'm saying like I
feel like The Evil Within was a good
solid first jump out the window at that
absolutely it was I feel like the studio
can do something uh to that caliber I
Hey listen I thought evil within two was
absolutely incredible and people just
slept on it they just it just didn't
sell well and it's unfortunate because
it was a really good game I hope they go
back to the franchise though to be
honest with you yeah I think they will
too and you know I think there's a lot
of stuff going on uh behind closed doors
you know what's funny is I had someone
leak me a picture of Banjo-Kazooie I
actually sent you a picture of it uh I
sent that to to my peoples my Claire I
call them my clarification peoples okay
people I send to that are in the know
and they all told me that it's [__]
okay it's fake as hell someone even
uh like found it on the internet and
sent it back to me
it's like this is where I came from
it kind of did look like the um
what was it nuts and bolts it did look
like a high-res version of that
as far as banjo then you know I say that
kind of you know but I say that's cool
though but yeah
yeah it is what it is I personally think
Banjo-Kazooie has a place in the Xbox
ecosystem if it's brought back correctly
and it's properly funded but I get it
but you know first off let's get the
five dollars to drive from Kraken dim
podcasts crack instead Den podcast wait
a minute the show endurance Ray tracing
can run at 60 frames but redfall can't
Lord have mercy hey Joey don't start it
you know I was thinking uh to go on my
camera and find the settings for 30
frames and be like we're in the redfall
show like but I didn't want to look in
that and and to be honest with you I I
changed too much on the settings no I
actually need to really get familiar
with this camera because for people who
don't know it it looks like I have like
a regular webcam I don't
like I have a DSL I think they that's
what they call it like Sony
a6400 camera with with like a stigma 4
uh 14 millimeter or 12 millimeter uh
lens like it I have a very good computer
a very good camera it's just I don't
know how to work the thing
like it it might as well be a foreign
language like I might as well be looking
at Japanese because I don't know
anything that's in the back and you know
maybe some YouTube videos talk to people
that actually know what's going on but
anyway
let's get into the show man let's get in
the show let's get into it man
can't survive without caught I'm sure
you've seen the Dilemma that's going on
where this is this is the new thing that
PlayStation loves doing weekly Dart you
know what that is finding how weak they
can look to the public that week and how
weak they can look to all these
regulation companies that's to try to
approve this Call of Duty deal so I'm
sure you've seen it I'm sure you've seen
where they said that you know kind of
I'm not going to be paracording but
they're pretty much like look you know
we as a company
can't compete with Call of Duty in our
company the PlayStation brand would
eventually crumble that's pretty much
what they said
the words that he used exactly will not
be able to recover
recover recover you know one would think
that revolving around your whole brand
around a a brand that you don't own
is kind of bad business practice when
you agree dirt yeah absolutely so tell
me what you think about this while I
open the front door because it's hot
okay well you know I've done a couple
videos about this we've been talking
about it the last few podcasts we've
done and um
listen guys you know how I feel well if
you don't know how I feel maybe you
don't listen to my channel maybe you're
not subscribed to my channel but let's
be honest guys um
Jim Ryan said if the Xbox version is
better than the PlayStation version of
Call of Duty
um they can't recover now if you're a
PlayStation first party developer how
old does that make you feel we
understand like like Alex just said we
know the PlayStation is trying to make
themselves seem weak for The Regulators
they're trying to play the victims so
they can you know get this deal blocked
but if you're a Neil drugman you're
Corey ballog and all of those guys and
you know how does that make you guys
feel he's saying this third party game
if they like okay first he said if they
lose it they can recover then he said if
it goes into Game Pass they can't
recover now he's saying if Xbox version
is better
they can't recover how does that make
make their first party feel I'm very
curious about that I think it's one of
those things I think it's one of those
things where it's not necessarily they
know they can't recover
I think they're talking like
at the end of every year we take that
money that we made from college and
that's a padding and they to their mind
if we lose that call to a huge degree it
would change the landscape of our
business
you know I would
God of War ghost of Shima which maybe
not ghosted but Last of Us unchartered
I would consider these the foundation of
PlayStation but
they got nice golden bars in the in in
the in the crib I would say that that's
Call of Duty they they love spending
money on stuff that that's not theirs
and when you get this amount of money
we're talking Millions to billions of
dollars but they're they're receiving
from Call of Duty it's easier to fund
other projects when you can count on
that money every year right now maybe
maybe they're being sincere maybe
they're like look like we've been able
to take a lot of risks in the past
because we can count on that Call of
Duty money to you know replenish some of
that money but if it's gone
and that's that's exaggerating obviously
wouldn't be gone but if it has been
severely damaged due to maybe a
Microsoft deal in the future they feel
less comfortable that they can maintain
what they've been doing throughout the
years that's the only way I can see it
that's the only way I can take it from
whether that they've described
yeah I understand what you're saying but
the latest round of crying Jim Ryan he
specifically said if Xbox version is
better when he says better what is he
talking about uh higher resolution a
couple of frames better what is he
talking about
I don't think he knows what he's talking
about to be honest see that's the point
I'm making now if Call of Duty being
removed from PlayStation absolutely
that's that that will hurt them
tremendously
Xbox getting the marketing deal I do
believe that will hurt them a little
also not as much as Jim Ryan is making
it seem it will hurt them but it would
definitely hurt them slightly because
marketing is huge and the Xbox start to
drop some bundles with Call of Duty in
there that Xbox game pass bundles that
will hurt PlayStation a little bit
not as much as Jim Ryan is saying so
I don't know man who knows maybe we are
so ignorant to the situation because we
don't know what's going on behind closed
doors maybe they're serious like look
like maybe they use more of that money
than we actually think because if you
think about it we're just looking at
like Logistics of how much money do they
make off of the the standard 60 things
once that they're talking about from a
monetary on war zone you know we get an
x amount of money every time someone
buys a skin in in war zone and if we
start to strip that away maybe they're
talking about that maybe they makes
maybe we are underestimating the amount
of money that is made off of Call of
Duty every year and they are not joking
when they say that I think they're
they're definitely
uh you know uh they're over exaggerating
but I don't think that the CR the core
root is exaggerated I think that they're
exaggerated will happen but I think that
there is a significant amount of damage
that can be done throughout the next 10
years by Xbox owning Call of Duty and I
think that's the whole point of Xbox
going after this they needed a big
enough player to get people to go in the
game pass and stay in Game Pass and I
think that PlayStation sees the
direction everything's going on their
concern is like look we think that if
they have access to Call of Duty and
they do this game pass thing we think
there's a chance throughout the next 10
years where they start draining our
resources because we're go they can get
these Call of Duty people off the Xbox
platform because let's be real here like
look at it from
a consumer sample look at it from a
person that just plays Call of Duty
because that's all they seem to care
about is Call of Duty and what's funny
is people act like that number is small
that number is only usually two months
out of the year and ourselves everything
the entire year
imagine you start like it's like
Microsoft buys that and they put a hole
in the bottom of it you know what I'm
saying it could be a small hole but
throughout the years it just drains more
and more and more and then when you
start having more and more of these
casual people transferring from the
older generation to the newer generation
they'll be like y'all can get Game Pass
and I could just pay 15 and keep it for
as long because most people will fall
off of Call of Duty within five to six
months after getting it and they'll wait
for the new one you know oh I can just
probably 15 have all these other games I
think that
I think that is their primary concern is
they're going to slowly lose the market
lead because of that Call of Duty thing
and and for people that don't think that
could be the case let me ask you this
every generation that has one
you can all you can in some way shape or
form Trace that back to Call of Duty
360. people could say what they want
PlayStation caught up it was after
you you can't declare Victory that's
like equivalent to doing a marathon
number one stops the number five keeps
running and he passes number one but the
race is over
right so but get what what did the 360
have that whole generation Burger
all of Duty Call of Duty marketing
what did PlayStation 4 have that whole
generation almost
Call of Duty marketing started in in
2015 to to the present yeah and by then
even at 2015 there they start marketing
on Xbox like that yeah so it's just like
look like
I do think they're exaggerating but a
part of me does understand their fear
their fear that they're going to lose
that lead because of how powerful the
Call of Duty voice is how powerful the
Call of Duty audience is how powerful
the people that play Call of Duty
because people we keep saying let's they
want to get the Casual audience they
want to get the Casual audience there's
no bigger way to get the Casual audience
than Minecraft 2K Call of Duty or Madden
I already own Minecraft
and now they get in Call of Duty
thanks
the only thing I'm going to say what you
said everything you said was was was
great points what I'm going to say
at the end at the end of the day addict
PlayStation
depending
on the third party game a third-party
game being that bread and butter
is going to significantly hurt them
because we've talked about Xbox in the
past some of the games that they had
they depended on third party to develop
these games and Xbox didn't own the the
uh IPS on like some of the IPS or the
studios and it came back to bite them
when they cannot make a sequel to those
games or the developer get acquired by
another you know publisher or something
so PlayStation depending on a
third-party game
it hurts that's like a smaller excuse me
a smaller YouTuber
having a couple of good months
financially
then all of a sudden he quit his real
job and said yeah
we good man it's gonna be my bread and
butter
then all of a sudden his numbers go down
he has no control over there's nothing
he can do if you want to be a full-time
content creator you should at least make
three to four times what you're making
currently right right or at least cover
your bills and your lifestyle
yeah
but that's my point so when you're
relying on something you really can't
control
no matter how long it takes it would
eventually hurt you
because
we had examples with Xbox Crackdown
three the cloud gen team got bought up
by another company Xbox had no control
over it they said damn what are we gonna
do now
you know like the same thing with
Insomniac no sunset overdrive too
because they got bought up by Sony so
when you rely on something you don't own
or something you have no control over it
is there's always the chance it can come
back and hurt you and we're seeing our
PlayStation and it's like the biggest
reason that I don't care realistically
what PlayStation goes through from this
Call of Duty thing yeah a couple super
chats that you see it I don't know if
you saw it yeah I'm gonna get them right
after this uh and let me see okay to
what we're talking about
um we got a final superf in the Nintendo
uh uh uh Donna taku yeah he changing his
name sometimes the only exceptional 70
game at 30 frames is tears of the
Kingdom scratch that the only acceptable
70 game is tears of the Kingdom ah man
you know tears I think it's about to
come out there and hit people in the gut
I really do you know we could talk about
that momentarily here in a second uh JD
gamer at the final Super Chat we people
that like Xbox need to stop falling and
promoting these false narratives of one
of the new why Xboxes trash nonsense
we'll go get to that we're gonna get to
that we we got any games that he's tired
of it we got a little bit to talk about
we're going to get to that you know I do
want to okay okay here's Donna Taco I'll
make you a day
tomorrow they're going to be showing
well at probably the last trailer for
Zelda
so next week we'll dedicate a whole
topic to Zelda because I I do think
that's going to be a very key game
I don't think it's gonna be like breath
of the wild I'm gonna be real with you
but I do think it's gonna be relevant
it's going to be uh extremely out there
I just don't know if it's going to have
the same domino effect where people
automatically assume
that it's going to be game of the year
because of the competition this year
that's my opinion on the matter but um
let's
let's go ahead and go straight into uh
Joseph Dayton
all right so Joseph Staton uh for those
of you that don't know he
he was in charge of the
of Halo infinite for a while
um I don't think he was directly in
charge but he had a lot of movement
there he had a lot of you know things
that he could do there and after Halo
infinite keep in mind he came from the
old day OG days like bungee days he came
back to try to get Halo back on track
apparently he reached out to Microsoft
because he was working for hololens or
something like that but he went back to
another department and now he is
officially left
343 and Microsoft in general yeah
Microsoft yeah uh so first thing I want
to ask you
um is that surprising to you do you
think we should be concerned uh on
Joseph stating leaving
um no because he left three four three
earlier this year or was that late last
year um I think it was like he left for
three yeah last year so him leaving
Microsoft no that that shouldn't concern
Us Xbox Gamers because he's leaving the
whole company not just three four three
um you know that happens all the time in
real life you know there's a lot of
people leave company leave big companies
um uh maybe Halo infinite the Halo
franchise is in good hands with Pierre
hence uh Heintz however you pronounce
his last name
um so I'm not really surprised man we
see this happen all the time people
leave all the time
um I am well maybe I'm a little
surprised that he's leaving the company
completely
but I'm not surprised because it happens
all the time so
and plus
here here's to what I think
um
I was adding a a topic uh to it because
I do see people talking about it all
right
is there a concern with him leaving I
don't think there's concern because I
think I don't I do think there is some
friction it's like I said on IOP last
week because I feel like
you can't go through the rough terrains
that he went without filling away you
know maybe it's not much maybe he kept
it completely professional uh but the
fact that he left because the when he
didn't leave you would think okay
everything's good they worked it out but
he's left like three or four months
later so I do think that there is a
little bit of friction but I don't think
it's any way shape or form where they
would never work together again I just
think it was one of those
I came out the bleachers I tried to save
Halo infinite I think he got burned a
little bit just a little bit because you
know even though that you really
shouldn't put too much of the
responsibility on him because he was
coming in on already uh engulfed ship
you can't get off that ship without
getting burnt a little bit
um because you know my Microsoft and
these corporations in general they uh
you know they they hold someone
accountable and the people that was
accountable already left so it was like
I do think that we're gonna have a
scenario where
now that Joseph's gone we might hear
some more information going on to him
but
I think at this point he was there for
like what 18 years
or something like that like look this
man worked for Microsoft for all these
years he tried to take one last hoorah
with with Halo again it didn't work out
and the reason I don't think there's
huge beef is because he went back to
another division
I felt like if there was serious beef
there would not have been none of that
this man's a lifer okay I I find it hard
to believe he couldn't afford to take a
couple weeks off and find another job
um he went there willingly and I think
it was one of those things where he went
there and you know it's like I said
there might be a little bit of tension
because he couldn't do what he achieved
what he wanted to achieve doing and I
would say that some of the the higher
ups put a little bit of the blame on
certain aspects to him but I don't think
it was enough to make him feel way I
think everyone knew what was going on
but at the end of the day
when the game launches
someone got to get some of the smoke and
I do think he got a little bit of it and
I think that's what probably resulted
him in leaving in general because he was
like look I did what I did
um I did everything I could do
um I was told he had his hands tied
behind his back a little bit there in
the development so I think that's
probably where some of the annoyance
came from and I think eventually he was
just like look
this is all I can do and I think I'm
ready to ride into the sunset when you
read his actual
message it kind of looks like he already
found another place to go it looked like
he was poached
could be I think this man shows up in in
Bungie yeah I'll be funny
there'll be some place he's familiar
with so yeah let me get these super
chats real quick uh because they might
be related to what we're talking about
then we'll get your opinions on it man
so we got a two dollar Super Chat from
Ray Ray redfall doesn't need a delay
stop crying uh we'll get to that right
right
we gotta find out the super chef from uh
JD gamer last gen Quantum break and Rise
got the whole resolution thing stop
assuming the Xbox just needs to do
whatever PlayStation does they don't all
right we're going to talk about rise in
Quantum break because I do think that's
a relevant conversation we can have uh
but it's gonna be later on in the show
because you guys know I don't like these
Dean Long most of the time we don't go
over an hour hour and a half unless we
have like King on because then King just
talks and talks and talks and you know
he he takes like 30 minutes by himself
but you guys know Kings Ranch they're
they're amazing 10 super trap from JD
gamer I blame Staton for the lack of
campaign content he was brought in to
specifically fix that Odin provide new
campaign content we've gotten new
multiplayer content new modes Forge but
no campaign we don't know what's going
on for all you know
that might be one of the things that you
know he might have left for because he
feels like they didn't do what he needed
to get done to get it because sometimes
when a game needs done doesn't
necessarily mean what a game needs done
to make money
sometimes you can say what you want all
the all you could say what you want to
your blue turn to your face turns blue
when you look at these you know top
people at 343 at Microsoft Xbox and
they're like okay but when am I gonna
make money off this
everything I just said isn't going to
bring you money like
butts it will help Halo infinite and you
know a lot of people hey uh Halo 343
some of the executives at Microsoft I'm
sure they're like look Halo infant it's
a duck you know it's best to cut and
move on and make a new project a new
Halo game obviously but I I wouldn't go
as far as to putting 100 blame on Joseph
stating for that because I do think
there's probably circumstances that led
to what happened with that but dirt tell
me what you think about Jefferson state
and leaving
like I said man um
I think you know we just don't know
what's really happening behind the
scenes
did he leave because he was upset about
something we don't know did he leave
because it was this time to move on we
don't know did he leave because he was
approached by another company we
obviously don't know so when you sit
back you think about it man you just
wish him the best you you hope Halo is
in good uh hands with Pierre hence
and that's it man that's all you can do
you know we see a lot of people leaving
companies going to different companies a
lot of people you know retiring so
that's just part of life not just the
gaming industry that's a part of life
well you know when like individuals who
got a 10 submission from JD gamer now
I'm blaming him where's my campaign
content what type of leadership did he
provide that allowed all the other
things were made but what he was brought
into never even got started I feel you
on that uh but what I will say is like
you said earlier JD gamer a lot of the
content you see in our halo infants
multiplayer um what is easily monetized
multiplayer single player multiplayer
and I think that is probably why you're
seeing more content in the multiplayer
fraction doesn't make it right you
should still get your single player
campaign single player content onto the
campaign I would have loved to it you
know it's looking like we may never see
what happened to atriox and you know
that ending cut scene from Halo infinite
and that sucks but at the end of the day
I do you know I can sit here and tell
you I'm not gonna play Halo the next
Halo but I'll probably be capping the
moment that drama playing
it's sad because they got us they got us
by our passion and to a point there's
nothing you can really do you either
put up or just shut up and I'm not
telling you to shut up JDM telling
myself you know I tell myself every time
there's certain games out there I'm like
look I'm a I'm an old strong with my
wallet and I go out here and you talk
all this nonsense like I do or if they
do this to Fable I'm done with Microsoft
they can come out there and drop the
complete bomb with my with Fable and
when that Elders grow six drops I know
what's gonna happen
well I know what's gonna happen I ain't
gonna hold strong to anything so I just
shut up at this point because I know
they got me by my passion what am I do
I'm gonna come up here I'm a [__]
because that's that's what I do I'm a
content creator if I don't like
something I'm gonna [__] about it but
at the end of the day I can't even
content create if I don't play the game
so I'm dead if I do and damned if I
don't
there you go
Artemis I wondering why redfall used
that FBS boost Tech to get 60 frames
they used on the older games we'll get
to that here in a second we'll get to
that here in a second
uh I guess we'll go ahead and get
straight into uh this Quantum Break
Stuff
um
there's been a lot of talks about brain
caught on breaks back not necessarily by
anyone from the actual Studios but a lot
of people want Quantum break back for
some reason and
it's looking like rice and Rome has a
lot of stuff going on with it I don't
know if you see what's going on but
right every time cryotech promotes a job
and if you look at their listings
it doesn't say it says a rise picture
but if you look at their listings uh it
says they're other games but it says an
un unannounced title as well okay look
maybe maybe I'm just maybe I'm capping
maybe I don't know what I'm talking
about maybe there for some reason
promoting the one game that they don't
really
had any success with now look rise was a
fun game to a lot of people but
commercially especially for a launch
title it didn't do the greatest it could
have done
but I do think
I think every game deserves a sequel I
do I think every game deserves a chance
to correct the mistakes that the uh that
the the uh that uh the predecessor did
but with stuff like Quantum break
conversations happening again with ryze
I'm gonna break this into two questions
for you one would you want a Quantum
break two or a rise to let me get the
Super Chat real quick JD gamer with the
ten dollars redfall doesn't need to do
anything other than be a great game
let's worry about that first and not all
the silly Sony
backed Xboxes trash narratives we're
going to talk about that here in a
minute JD we're going to talk about here
in a minute stay around stay around man
you gotta subscribe to my channel man
you like talking that [__] yeah so uh go
go
rise too I would want rise in in the
heartbeat that would be an easy decision
Quantum break was a solid game but rise
I just felt was so underrated
um it was during that time where Xbox
was getting so much hate no way is right
son of Rome a 60 Metacritic bro
6-0 no way
it was just getting so much hate because
Xbox is getting so much hate at that
time and it was XBox exclusive so
I believe if that game because you know
I don't know if people realize that rise
was initially a connect game
and for whatever reason they made it a
full-fledged game but I'm sure pretty
sure they only had a two-year
development cycle with rice to make it
what it became and it's incredible bro
yeah it was a connect it was a connect
game
um so I just feel that rise too would be
incredible
that's that game to me impressed me so
much yes people say it was always
repetitive every game is repetitive
damage so it was as the the story was
good the graphics was absolutely amazing
that game still looks pretty good to
this day
rise two will be the game keep talking
about go to Quantum break now
yeah Quantum break I enjoy Quantum break
uh but to be honest I would prefer rise
um I've been playing Quantum break
recently that's for some gameplay
footage on my YouTube channel
hey man it's a good game um but rice
that's that's what I want
no doubt about it I get the Super Chat
since you go yeah
JD gamer with the two attic what do you
really know about rise too
hmm
you on mute bro
Alec you're on mute
I can't go into that JD I can't go under
that man see I don't talk about I I
don't quote unquote leak stuff
but if it gets like sometimes I kid you
not I've I've talked to people that tell
me stuff and they're like yo don't tell
anybody
then I see a video pop up on YouTube and
then if I start seeing like ran Diller
all them making videos I'm hitting my
dude up like dude can I make one like
everyone else is eating why can't I
right
listen right so if they show rise too if
rise two is announced I don't know this
year or even next year that will be a
they will have to end the show with that
they will have to end the show with rise
because
that's a game that most Xbox fans want
here's my question to you little dirt
do you think Xbox back that truck up and
get rise as an exclusive
in the properties that they don't own I
get that I understand why they do what
they do now with buying Studios but to
me this is an exception this isn't one
of those you know uh this isn't an IP
that could I just personally feel like
if you leave that out in the wild too
much sure it might mature and come out
for everybody
but there's always that chance at the
last minute Sony pops through and they
snatch that
and today yeah how bad would it look
if this year at PlayStation's conference
Rye shows up opening that show and it's
a PlayStation exclusive
I agree see let me tell you this
Alum wake was a game right remember was
it 2018 or early 2019 when Xbox gave
Alan Wake back to remedy
and the conversation was oh snap it's
going to be a PlayStation 5 exclusive
that's what everybody was saying because
they gave the IP back to remedy now even
me I was like oh man it's gonna be so
terrible if PlayStation gets Alan Wake 2
as an exclusive obviously it's a
multi-plat okay fine but
just that point right there to scare me
like oh if PlayStation gets Alan way too
as an exclusive so I agree with you if
rise two is the thing it's a 100 ba XBox
exclusive because it was originally an
XBox exclusive we heard Rumblings back
in the day that cry Tech and Microsoft
kind of got into it over the rise IP
I don't know if XBox wants to make a
sequel if they wanted to buy the IP but
cry Tech didn't want them to buy it and
they kind of got into a little beef
that's what I heard don't know how true
that is but wise two should be uh XBox
exclusive
I understand that they wouldn't have no
no control for the rise but I think it's
mainly just me looking at it from like a
like a perception how good would it be
if they ended this conference this year
with a rise sequel
this year
and it's an XBox exclusive like that
would be incredible dude it would take
over the internet
it would take over there but you know
what's crazy there is a realm
where it didn't happen with one game
because it's already been announced as
multiply but we saw a Tomb Raider just
because it's announced some don't mean
nothing if there's a realm where Sunset
Overdrive 2
rice in a room two and Allen wake 2 all
Xbox originated games could be on a
PlayStation platform exclusively
hmm
just it's not the Sunset Overdrive 2
it's not a matter of if it's a matter of
when PlayStation's eventually going to
trigger that there's no way they don't
they they the king of Patty they will
spend a couple hundred million dollars
just to be Petty easy I know they
wouldn't
so I I think that's just my thing it's
like I would love for them to open up
the uh open up the gates get that
get that game man I think rise would be
especially if it's a good rise man like
rice subtle Rome 2 might not have been
the greatest XBox exclusive but I do
think it engaged the most interest and
out of all the stuff that happened on
the the Xbox one I do think it has the
most potential to really go out there
and be great
yep I agree
yeah I think I think record too but I
think at this point I think recourse
just just a dream it is I think it's
just a dream I believe right isn't being
some before recore yeah I know I think
record would be made before Rise
um because they own recore I think it
would be easier to find a studio to make
record than it would be that's a good
point negotiate with cryo attack well
it'd just be interesting man and I think
people don't realize sure we might not
see that but I think optically and the
internet would take that very well I can
already see the the Articles Xbox making
uh some things on the Xbox one
generation right you know like giving
games that we've been saying for years a
sequel like I get I get King's Point
Kings is like look they don't own it
they're not gonna invest if they own it
then they would invest I get that but at
the same time it's like this is Rise
we're talking about like this isn't
I I think I think that's where maybe
just because I enjoyed the game and it's
been years since I played it maybe I
should go maybe I should stop capping a
game for I haven't played since like
2015-14 maybe I should go back and play
but you know I remember getting the Xbox
One and Rise was the first game I had
and I remember me and my friend John
staying up all night and playing it
it it was it was
we want something like rise for the Xbox
series X
and you would be crazy
if rice turned around two
was the game we're looking for if they
made yeah it's just it's just crazy that
that you look at something like
um Star Wars Old Republic
huge for the original Xbox PlayStation's
exclusive there you go and it's just
like games like that I know in the grand
scheme of things it's it's irrelevant it
doesn't mean anything
but I do think enough of these
enough of these situations that keep
happening you're going to start seeing
people like yo I noticed that yo I
noticed that and I think that's the
biggest issue we're having right now is
I feel like some of these games people
aren't thinking it's it's a big deal but
it is because when you consistently see
these titles going to the to go into the
competition
and imagine with like as an Xbox
consumer they're like look why should I
invest into an Xbox when I invested in
Xbox One and somehow all the all the
games that I was intrigued by got
sequels on the PlayStation yeah exactly
exactly I thought you just had the
perfect example of Kotor like you just
said Kotor that's that was the next
original Xbox game now the sequel is on
at an exclusive for the PlayStation so
why couldn't rise why shouldn't rice on
the wrong two be exclusives you're
absolutely right and I get they could
easily go for the we're gonna get rice
to the Roman game pass and I think that
that would be relevant that would be
pretty big move
but I am getting a little bit annoyed I
don't know about you dirt I think we've
talked about this and you disagree with
me I am getting a little bit annoyed by
the willingness
to go out there and secure a game for
Game Pass but not the willingness to get
at least one or two time exclusives
especially when you need them like when
you really need them like 2022. like
that's when Microsoft should have opened
up crack that biggie uh that that piggy
bank
and said yo we need this game because we
need this game like there ain't nothing
to play in 2023 too for the most part we
need this because we need a library this
this holiday but it just seems like
instead of doing that they're okay with
we're going to give you games and Game
Pass to keep you in and look I've said
it over and over again it's hard to
[__] when you have stuff to play
when you're consistently updating game
pass with pretty solid IPS going into
the service it's hard to [__] when you
have access to these titles because
you're you're doing something but I do
think we gotten to the point where
it's not enough look Game Pass is a good
tool Game Pass is good subscription
service but me personally I feel like it
needs to be sprinkled in with the timed
exclusive or two every now and then you
don't got to do what you used to do
Microsoft you own enough Studios to
cover the majority of this stuff but if
you see someone making a new IP that
looks interesting that looks Innovative
go in there and sprinkle some money and
get that because you know what that
might be a truck that throws you into
the next thing next gen that might be
your Titanfall that throws you thing
imagine if Microsoft didn't get none of
these games what would they be right now
true but let's be fair there were a
couple of games last year that word time
exclusives I'm gonna have to be in your
type of games
but they were timed exclusives you know
high on life that's one that was a good
game I still ain't played it but I will
concede to that one yeah I finished it
was a great game um now the other one I
actually didn't really care for was
scoring that was a little yeah I don't
really care for it but
um but I see what you're saying uh you
mean like more bigger AAA time exclusive
I understand I think my issue is you're
doing something
when your competition has no problem
doing it a bunch yeah like they they try
to get star filled imagine there's a
realm where Starfield would have been
exclusive to PlayStation
you know I get it they bought the whole
company so they just naturally got star
filled and I'm cool with that but
sometimes
it makes more sense to go in there and
just pluck a piece off the board than it
is to buy the board now you could buy
multiple boards but there's some boards
that can't be bought that you could just
pluck a piece off of and it's just as
good
yeah I understand what you're saying but
I think Microsoft's vision is not worth
it like a big AAA
third party exclusive I think they would
rather have it in Game Pass
than to
you know say what if they got the time
exclusive would win six months it would
be in Game Pass too yeah yeah true but
that also would be more money also but I
think
them their first party is more important
like King said like you said King said
their first party is more important
um so I understand where they're coming
from because you know time exclusives
has hurt them in the past
but I see where you're coming from also
where you know sometimes if you know
it's going to be slow
sign the time exclusives but maybe their
future they're thinking like they're
never going to be slow after 2023
they're going to have constant content
dropping you know maybe that's what it
is too maybe they know look things gonna
be rough now
but
we know what's coming and we know we got
an army they just slow they got tanks to
crawl around they gotta take around
helicopters they just slow like yeah
yeah I mean that's possible bro like
they're like yo listen
we got our developers cooking up some
stuff
they're going to be ready and they're
going to be consistent
one AAA game every quarter a couple of
you know double A games in there and
they might have so much content that
they feel they don't need any more time
exclusives that's my opinion I could
obviously be wrong so
let's get these super chats to go on to
the main event of the evening I see
people in the chat they still trying to
get that redfall content you about to
get it calm down
the angry therapist with the five dollar
Super Chat that was dope
uh just with they had more weapons uh to
use in that game I think he's talking
about Quantum break I don't know
am I right rise
yeah it's hard to tell you could be
talking about either one of them to be
honest with you both of them I didn't
play a whole lot of quantum break
because I dropped it but I could
understand find out super shot from JD
gamer Microsoft is acquiring inquiry
Tech I called it you heard it here first
folks they're getting that IP and the
cryo engine I would be cool that would
shut me up
um I think that rise is a very important
title and you know if if the studio is
willing to be bought and Microsoft has
like really evaluated if they can get
anything from that purchase and it
actually turns fruit then I would say do
it you know but because they do got some
games as a service they the cryo engine
has been updated I don't know how well
we have to see that with if they make a
rise too but I do think rise will be
announced this year sometimes I really
do because they're getting very extra
with announcing that they're getting
very extra with that
um nice we gotta find all the super trap
from gamer by choice we need to
understand that Microsoft does not have
the same view of games like we do
they're not attached to them as much as
we
money makers we are the money makers I
get it they are money marketers but the
the people a lot some of the people
running the studio they're they're
definitely Gamers but I understand what
you're saying from that they're looking
at from a pure you know money-wise is
rye is going to bring in the money to
justify the cost in getting it
um five dollar Super Chat from JD gamer
Quantum break would be wonderful and if
they actually delivered the game that
was originally uh
envisioned see I have to get close
they were both you know when the games
are intertwined yeah
five dollar Super Chat from Dave Ramos
replaying Quantum break the Blended
medium is fantastic way ahead of its
time
and then two dollar super jump TX uh
thx1138 we need Quantum break on series
X with an FPS boost and then we got the
angry therapist sorry I was talking
about rise man we didn't you didn't need
to Super Chat that man but appreciate it
appreciate it all right let's hang the
therapist what's up bro yeah let's get
into it man 53 minutes uh I'm gonna 53
minutes give this to the time stat Mafia
we'll get it 40 seconds
let me give you the Super Chat while you
um
JD gamer with the 10. one more
prediction folks addict addict do a poll
on this Microsoft is going to acquire
Platinum Games and they're going to
finish scale bound and deliver to us in
E3 of our dreams of Dreams scale bomb
rise two on Quantum break [__]
that's a lot
I don't know if Microsoft want to rock
out with Platinum bro
uh man I know
diversion five minutes quantum
Platinum gains is worth the purchase
but
there's a butt
they got to make sure that they ain't
making 50 000 projects right one to two
make the A and A B Team call today we
ain't working on whatever Activision
wants it'll work on because I do think
that
you could say easily say that when it
comes to the core of Platinum Games
they've never made a bad game
now when you go off on the Avatar things
I liked Avatar but I get why people
don't like that what about Babylon Falls
but I feel like that that's for I I feel
like that wasn't the core of platinum I
feel like
the core Platinum is is that vein of the
of the near automatas the vein of you
know uh Bayonetta I feel like that's
their core that's their bread and butter
and when they make a game in that rain
in that vein it's always hitting out the
park
I guess and Microsoft could really use a
studio like that they really could all
right let's get a red file
all right red fall today was announced
that red fall is a 30 frames game
it's not a 60. now obviously eventually
they're going to do a patch uh to make
this game a 60 frames game but we've
seen in the past where sometimes those
patches can take up to a month of three
to six to even a year and that is going
to take on the longer inside probably
take about three months hopefully I
would
I
this is one of the biggest drops that I
think Microsoft has done in a couple
months
like
first off I want to address kid smooth
he went out there like
kind of insinuating that people are
holding information that went into these
previews I know people that went to
these previews I don't think that was
asked to the people I know
because I just don't think that
but
someone had to have asked that question
I find it hard to believe that no one
asked that question the entire event
yeah I don't know if someone asked that
question maybe someone did
but you know
even if they did ask that question and
the Bethesda uh hit them with an NDA on
it or just PR talk to work I think you
guys need to realize that like
talking with these companies sometimes
can be a lots of like
PR things where you have to word things
certain ways
it's it's the bad of the industry and
but
from what I've seen on Bethesda they're
usually more transparent than that I
think maybe this is one of those things
where maybe they expected to get it done
but something happened and they couldn't
finish it
because they they've been very open with
that in the fact that they haven't said
anything makes me think that maybe this
is something that happened recently it's
not like they always intended on it not
being there maybe they just couldn't get
it working at launch but regardless if
they couldn't get working at launch it's
unacceptable it's not there at launch
what do you think Dirk I gotta eat
something to drink
yeah let's go
um
listen I gotta be honest guys when I saw
that news I was like ah damn yeah I was
I was let down by that because
where it follows this game I'm still
hyped for and I do believe it should
have a 60 frames per second option
um in my eyes I just think this means
like the game needed a little bit more
time
um and they didn't want to delay it
again you know in today's gaming a lot
of uh Gamers oh I'm sorry a lot of teams
developers they'll post
you know they have post launch stuff
that come out a month or two later
adding extra things but I gotta be
honest guys this game should have 60 FPS
at launch
it's okay to criticize XBox guys if
you're Xbox fan is okay now I'm not
about to go above and beyond and doom
and gloom like some people but yeah man
um it was it was a huge letdown
it's a huge letdown man um and I'm not
sure I want to play FPS at 30 in 2023 I
love Arcane I love uh what I mean like
redfall looks incredible to me
I'm gonna see how it plays initially and
hopefully they bring out that past ASAP
and I'm sure that's their focus seeing
this backlash I hope I don't know if
they get some people from like from some
other teams to help them out to try to
get this 60 FPS at launch I think that's
really important man I bet you 20 bucks
to have an emergency meetings right now
on how to handle it
hey yo Chris Hart I know this is in my
channel
but are we sure it's the real Chris Hart
yeah this is him I can tell Chris Hart
please stand up
hey boy I'm telling you boy but lucky
this ain't my channel because you have
to you acting like Jim Ryan just didn't
didn't go out there and throw all the
PlayStation first party Studios up on
the bus this little red for our news
y'all got y'all pigs and chips
he wasn't saying nothing he disappeared
but now we're talking about real far you
got your little punk chest sticking out
like you're really doing something
see that's what I Hate About You
PlayStation guys
I hate you I'm sorry go ahead look I
think this is unacceptable
um I will be playing this on PC if it
has 30 frames I just at this point
they're I'm not playing 30. it's just
not happening like it would be different
if it was like a one-off thing you know
when play uh play thing happen playing
that oh I didn't play that and to me as
long as I have an option which is called
PC to play it on I'm okay with having
that option but it doesn't excuse it it
doesn't yeah excuse the fact that they
really thought it was a good idea to
come out here in 2023 with as much power
talk you know love Aaron Greenberg to
death love him to death
but man's you said a couple years ago
the 60 was the standard and 120 would be
the exceptions yeah where's that energy
Aaron
I need that energy someone needs to save
me because I I I'm struggling I'm
struggling right now
I'm hoping and praying that they're
talking to each other and they're like
look we didn't realize that backlash we
was going to get for this
can we pull more resources and get this
done in two weeks that's what I'm hoping
I'm hoping
everything in me is like that is a
fantasy don't think
and let me tell you something addict um
you know last year you know like most
games were 30 last gen so it it so it
wasn't until this generation that I
really felt the 60 FPS bro like uh I
really didn't because because I'm not a
PC Gamer so I really didn't feel it last
generation the X the 60 FPS but I'm
going to tell you the game specifically
when they added a 60 FPS mode in
Assassin's Creed uh Valhalla I felt it
bro
I said oh I can't go back to 30. I feel
this and most games are 60 FPS on
Console like I said I'm not a PC Gamer
and when you have an FPS it should
definitely be 60 at launch bro I cannot
damage control this I cannot Fanboy it
I hope like you said I hope they're
trying to get some resources hey yo oh
listen give this guy some help
um Arcane Leon give those guys some help
we need to get this game at exit 60fps
at launch if they have to delay it for a
week so be it I do want the game to be
60fps all right let me get let me make
sure I get all the super chats before I
get to him
uh uh because JD going man JD going
um
man they they you guys have been mad
good this to me this this week man uh
bone and slave announcing uh with the
five dollars announcing redfall has a 60
patch is emitting the game is unfinished
and won't hit expectations at launch I
agree with you on that
I think the game still be good though
two dollars per shot from t uh hx1138 I
bought a series X for 60 frames as
standard yet and to be honest with you
Aaron Greenberg set its standard so it
to me everyone has every right to be
upset but I will agree with JD and dirt
that
it's 30 frames but it's not gonna mean
it's a bad game it just means it's not
going to run as good as it could ran we
got a 10 super draft from JD gamer with
stop with these move the goal post
narratives we need a great game and
anyone talking about how they can't play
30 Fray uh anyone talk about they can't
play 30 frames they better not even be
playing a Nintendo game saying it's
great on PS first party
you got me a little bit there here's the
thing though okay I'm gonna defend
myself a little bit JD I gotta play
those games on on the Nintendo as that
that
fidelity
I don't have to play these these
consoles as that
I could play it on PC and I think that
Microsoft doing these things and giving
options to play these games on PC but
you could play the PC Forum on a far
better frame rate it's kind of a slap in
the face it really is like because you
can play
I don't mind saying PC place is the best
place to play but I do think we're like
Xbox is here right now PC's here we need
that to be elevated and a little bit
shorter of of a gap
you know I get it I do there's a lot of
things going on but but one thing I will
say is like one thing I will say is JD
like Patty I'm in a podcast
one thing I will say is I do feel
we do need to stop with the us moving
goal post things
we're just upset we're not getting to
play this game at the best
you know performance we can like I feel
like if if you don't is that now like JD
30 frames might not be an issue to you
more power to you
I think that is a fair assumption a fair
point to say yo you guys are bugging 30
frames don't bother me I'm still playing
I rock with you with that statement
but I do think it's kind of crazy for
you to tell me that I can't say 30
frames is ridiculous and I because I'm
not telling you about your 30 friends
and you're willing to play that and I
think I played I play Destiny on PC and
I think this is this is when the frame
rates matter to me JD let's let's talk
let's Story Time with attic right now I
was playing Destiny on consoles for
years years with years
never had an issue always one of those
people said I don't understand how
people notice the frame rate difference
this is kind of ridiculous years I was
like this
but then I played
Destiny on PC
got a PC built just to play Destiny
played it on 60 frames at like 720p
because my PC was trash
guess what happened my whole mindset
with the process was done I actually
feel like frame rates is extremely
important but you know what I think
something that people don't consider
is the field of view I feel like that is
just as important as the as the frame
rates itself because it makes the game
feel quicker than it is well maybe it
makes the game feel as quick as it was
supposed to be from the start so I I
think that that's my biggest issue is
like people aren't I can understand
people playing at 30 frames but like JD
let me two let me eat two if I have an
issue of not playing a game in 30 frames
oh that ball doing JD it ain't bothering
you it's bothering me
uh but I I get what you guys are saying
I do think that there's a difference
between the people
that generally wanted to play this at 60
frames the people that are using this as
a clutch and a tool to attack the other
fan base
all right so uh
did uh okay yeah I read that
sorry guys I went on a little rant there
we got to chill from bone Slave at 30
frames redfall better look amazing yeah
once again I think it will I think see
I've seen a couple of those Fidelity
modes those graphical modes they look
really good at 30 frames it's just me
personally I can't play the 30 frames
and at least I'm just being real with
you guys
um we got a two-hour shoots up from uh
ordinary thoughts on Starfield if it's
30 frames PC my dude PC
what do you think you gonna are you just
do you have a PC to play games like that
no no I I was thinking about getting
something this summer
um because I got like a basic PC you
know for podcasting and stuff I was
thinking about getting like a little
gaming PC nothing too too expensive but
just something you know
um but I don't know
we'll see what happens five dollars from
JD gamer I want party uh let me make
sure yeah parody I want parody of
criticism between all the consoles and
if we don't do that what are we doing
now uh no I'm not I'm out uh I'm out
here collecting receipts we need to be
fair I agree with you I feel like even
myself I don't really put Nintendo to
the fire like that and I think I'm
falling into the line where a lot of
people's following where we just assume
that's Nintendo at this point you're
right like we need to be harder on
Nintendo but if to be fair if you look
at all my reviews I always say the
performance is dog [__] every single
time every review I've ever done with
the title almost I've been very vocal
about that play this on PC when it comes
out for PC I've always been vocal on
that but at the same time
when it comes to redfall Starfield we
have other alternative places to playing
that that's not 30 frames and I think
that's why they get a little bit less
smoke because you do have those
alternative ways of playing it
uh you got anything to say about that I
know you love Nintendo
no I you know
like I said bro uh everything is fair
the auto criticism is fair
they deserve the criticism definitely
should be an option bro it the options
should be there at lunch flat out yeah
yeah and I think that's it too JD like
the other consoles don't
like the other consoles don't put Power
on their chest as much as Xbox
like you got you know like I said Aaron
Greenberg saying the 60s going to be the
standard so people assume that like I
have to take what the head of marketing
says for the literal sense
and I think that's where the disconnect
is with the other calls was like I'm not
saying don't give the other console
smoke get PlayStation smoking Nintendo
smoke
we give them all smoke but I will admit
that I am a little bit more like
accepting when Nintendo does it I need
to be better on that I need to put them
to the fire too but I think I just at
this point
I've seen the Landscaping of trying to
reach Nintendo's thick skull and it
doesn't seem to ever work
so I think that's what it is it it's
like I said earlier like they got us
they got us by our hobby they know we're
Gamers and especially content creators
it's hard to really stand on a square
because it's either we don't cover the
game and we get caught a fraud for
comedy on the game or we comment on the
game and we get caught a fraud for not
saying everything about the game so it's
it's a hard thing it's a hard thing to
go through ten dollar Superstar from the
start Lord Star Killer like that game
man like that game isn't that what no um
so we'll put in the chat what what the
dude from Unleashed what was his
nickname I think it was Starkiller
I don't know someone put in the chat
though I'm gonna be looking in a second
10 super shot from Star kill uh Lord
Star Killer Arcane really dropped the
ball quality mode should be 60 frames on
the Xbox Series xns 120 frames should be
the performance mode I want to see much
more of this full r d r DNA 2 features
of the XBox exclusive ASAP I've always
said never would have talked about that
RDA our DNA too because I feel like to
this day I still hear about that you
know what's crazy when you got
PlayStation Fanboys coming out there
saying crazy statements like four
teraflops of Titans and then they're
over there saying it's just crazy how
the the board switches it's crazy what
well hey like don't forget the guy that
said the Xbox cloud is is power quest
for Titans he's on the PlayStation
a lot of things that people don't
realize I think some of you realize a
lot of people do this stuff because it's
easier money
well you know it's there is a huge
amount of people that is willing to
spend money to talk [__] about Xbox and
I've seen it I've seen it
yeah and it is what it is you know I try
to keep my stuff a little bit away from
the console or stuff
um sometimes I like dabbling my foot in
it but you know it it just it just
depends on what's going on man it
depends on what's going on you gotta
find out super gamer by choice I can't
tell the difference between 30 and 60
unless digital family tells me I do not
want to tell others how to consume their
games I can't tell I feel you get
um gamer by choice here's the thing I
used to be like that I'm playing this
game at 30. but I really want to
emphasize and really want to to like put
a spotlight in
turn that
don't mess with the field of view
and play it at 30. and then max out your
field review or put at 90. some people
like it at 90. and put the field of view
to 90 or above that and then put it to
60. I think you'll feel more of a
difference in that because if you play
Destiny
at 60 and the field of view it's way
more you just feel faster you feel like
the game's faster your characters faster
and the reason is because they've panned
your screen back so you see more of your
screen so it's soon you're really
realistically going the same speed you
were but you're seeing more of it so it
looks like you're faster
um
um let me see
oh you got a member chat yeah it's
ridiculous I can't keep eye you guys
have been way too kind today man you
guys have been way too kind today give
her my choice it's a 40 member chat I do
not think Xbox realized that devs were
not going to update their engines to
take advantage of the benefits they put
into the series X I agree with you on
that and to a point they can't really do
a whole lot of that because you can't
put mandates on stuff to that degree
because then you won't get whole games
um five dollar Super Chat from Nintendo
uh Donna Taco X you Xbox dudes will will
try to shift blame to everyone else but
won't take accountability for the
console you're you're Shilling for sad
cases I I do it I do it I ain't gonna
lie like sometimes
I think I throughout the years I I've
de-attached myself from the Xbox Brands
as much as I used to be invested into it
now I just don't care I really don't
two years three four years ago you would
have told me I had to play redfall on
the PC to get the kind of performance I
wanted to
dirt I would have bitched I had a [__]
but I just don't care anymore man uh
five dollar Superstar from JD gamer I
got a super powered SSD why am I still
at 30 frames per second for Sony first
party games it's this double standards
that I'm calling out super powered SSD
yeah but we have called out
PlayStation's SSD multiple times
you know Ratchet and Clank is a 30 frame
per second game and I don't think it
should be a 30 frame per second game I
remember that was 30 frames right
I don't remember okay if it is uh look
hey let me double check
is
but uh I think what it is JD is I think
just people just want to play the games
at the best possible thing and look at
something like Jedi I play Jedi at 60
frames I think that's the issue here is
like we're not getting the option you
should have the option for 60 in any
game
and I think that's the issue we should
have the option
um clearly it's an issue because they
went and they said that they were going
to fix it in the future because people
like me I want that option I don't I
never play anything in Fidelity mode or
quality mode what the hell they call it
I always play at a performance and I
think there's a lot of people out there
I know some PlayStation people have no
problem playing their game at 30 frames
because they get that higher Fidelity
but I don't care about none of that I
played Happy Wars for like two years
that's like a cartoon game I don't care
about none of that
I just want to play the game the like in
the best performance because especially
the games I like to play the Dark Souls
type of games uh you know hardcore RPGs
heavy combat games these games is when
frames mean a lot and they can be
relevant
uh you know what attic you know let me
say this right quick before we go deaf
Loop had a 60 FPS mode and I played it
with that ghostwire Tokyo has a 60 FPS
mode I'm playing that now I'm playing
that now um so I wonder why redfall
doesn't have it I'm telling you I think
it was something that was originally
supposed to be at launch but something
happened it got pushed back
um
because I think that's another thing
people that they've not been very
transparent with this if they would have
said six months ago that this is gonna
be 30 frames I think people wouldn't be
as hard on them but they waited two
weeks so a lot of people already have
their pre-order in I think that's the
biggest issue here uh regardless if
that's true if that's right or not you
know that's that's subjective uh because
I do feel like they could do whatever
they want till the game comes out it's
just they're the ones that's going to
get the backlash it's their bra it's
their brand I can't tell them how to how
to promote their brand but in in modern
technology being transparent is gonna be
way easier on you than not being
transparent because what happened today
they got they got literally cut by the
the the the ankles and drove through the
fire yeah but who knows like you said I
hope they're like yo you know what we
have to get this to 60 in two weeks like
you said get some resources hey we got
to get this game in 60 man delay it for
a week you got to get a 60. two dollar
super drop from John TJ no excuse for a
red uh fall Forza Motorsport 7 is for uh
4K 60. all right so I got a question for
you I got a question for you
if they came up to you right now to hurt
and they said yo
we need we need a month
it's up to you do we delay right fall
month
for that 60 frames patch yes
so see here's here's where I'm a little
indifferent okay
who am I to delay the game off of a
preference that I'd like to play
but I do think it would make on the
grand scheme of things it would be
better for the brand
because I think giving only like I don't
know how many people probably way more
people play it at 30 frames than it's
going to play in a performance mode uh
they got the numbers on this clearly
they felt confident enough to come out
there and jump out the window this
morning over it but who am I to tell
someone that they got to wait another
month
just because I didn't get to play the
game I want to play the way I want to
play I think that's a very
back and forth conversation I I don't
think that that's a gray area
listen
we want the game to be at its best at
launch right I mean we wanted to be to
be at his best at launch a 60 FPS option
should be there at lunch you know I'm
not going to bend like Fanboy this or
diamonds controllers it should be there
Lawrence flat out you know so that's all
I'm saying you know it's not like with
the with the Last of Us PC uh uh stuff
and guys were blaming the PC
and not naughty dog and uh iron Galaxy
you know so so you just got to be real
with it you know yeah I hear you we got
a two dollar drawing TJ no excuse for
redfall Forza Motorsports is uh seven is
4K 60. I don't really know much about
like developing stuff like that so I
wouldn't know if that's impressive or
not like I I don't know how hard it is
to develop a a racer compared to
something like red fall like I think you
would have to actually get a debt I know
a few deaths I think I'm gonna start
braiding in some devs and people with us
and I I am in talks of like Colin
Moriarty bring him on here to like pick
his brain I know a lot of you don't like
Colin but I I think Colin speaks his
mind and I respect that even Colin was
one of those people he would speak his
mind even though he knows that that the
the fan base he is talking to is
building up a Spirit Bomb to hit him in
the face with it he'll still speak his
mind he'll he I like the people that
don't mind the smoke you bring back to
them and he doesn't really mind that and
I I like I said I know some of you don't
like calling and that's fine but but you
know it'd be one of those things where
you know we'll have an engaging
conversation with them because one thing
I do know about Colin is he won't
disrespect you just because he disres
did he disagree he's with you and that's
the people I want to bring on people
don't realize how hard it is to find
reasonable PlayStation people
that their first is not too many yeah
because I've seen it Colin will keep it
PlayStation he will keep a talking
PlayStation a lot of the PlayStations
are brain here what are they going to do
the first thing we talk about
PlayStation
Dart from your experience was the first
thing they're gonna do
they're going to divert it to Xbox
the first thing they're going to do even
though Colin has been talking about Xbox
a lot lately though but yeah
Xbox flips I've seen of them he he's
fair about it if he brings up Xbox it's
relevant to the point like I've seen
people literally you'll talk about
something completely unrelated and
they'll bring up completely unrelated
thing about Xbox
uh we got a two dollar Super Chat
for uh Mac City ENT yeah Max City
Entertainment that's the homie man Max
City Entertainment I appreciate you in
case you're new Max City because I don't
think I've ever read a super chat from
you I don't pronounce it very well so uh
I apologize
uh no 60 no play Us Xbox fans deserve
better delay I don't I just and Maxine
is a bot like me man but he's being
honest you know two dollars
great show fellas gotta go date night
all catch replay I appreciate that man I
appreciate that I think
I think what I'll do for you
um
what I'll do for you
is I'll put where we left off
just for JD gamer because he
he engaged a lot of the conversation
today so I'll put where we left off just
so he can come back and actually watch
what we were doing it's gonna mean the
red football content JD don't expect
this treatment every week I'm feeling
very generous today
goodness
uh like like me we would snipe Chris
hard like several times already you know
he'll come back with a different account
snipe
this is that Chris are the only thing
that gets me is when you're
disrespectful I don't care as long as
you do as long as you're respectful you
can say what you want and what's funny
is I worked in I worked in a dish for
two years I can talk mad smack to you
and I and it sounds like I'm being
nothing but respectful
it's crazy when you learn how to deal
with angry people and you learn how to
keep your composure of angry people
you'd be surprised at how Savage you can
be without saying nothing disrespectful
now Chris has some digital scrapbook
stuff he said hey like game passes for
poor people with blah blah blah so hey
Chris man you know I'm a mod over here
you better watch what you say to me just
time him out keep titing them out he has
some little thing with King I can't
block him because the King King King
loves that dude I I don't really
crispy a little bit too much uh
oh I see a fame fame we we about to end
here soon uh I I'll send them your way
I'll send them your way
got gotta represent gotta show people
some love man I said let me go away
it depends on who's on because I see I
send them to them all the time but I'm
pretty sure they're like the only people
that's on at this time
but anyway you know I think I just think
when it comes to this
we just want what's best I I think
that's it bro I think we could all agree
on that you know there's a chance that
this won't hurt redfall at all
but there's a chance that if they had
that performance mode and a lot of
people were talking about more in a
positive way the chance that we would
have a way more perception a way bigger
day one for this game than it was and I
think that's the part that just
irritates me it's like it just feels
like no matter what happens if XBox can
find a right to step on they're gonna
step on a rake
um they could be in the middle of a
giant desert
got plenty of places to go left plenty
of places to go right there'll be a big
ass sign that says don't walk here
plenty of rakes and Microsoft like we're
gonna go that way like and it's just
like I think that's the biggest issue I
was like dude you guys got this man you
you do so much good and then you step on
a rake and it kind of hurts you right
yeah I just want that to stop like I
feel like they have so much potential
their Studios can generate so much
different copper games you could do this
you just gotta stop stepping on rakes
and sometimes they step on a rake get
hit in the face and keep walking and
step in another rake
shoot option from TX uh THX one one
three eight four spoken running seven
720p on PS5 Fanboy not talking yo okay
first off they weren't talking about the
resolution because everyone else was
dogs piling anything else for smoking
related I honestly think that was the
most talked about
gain this year by far yeah it was uh
pretty bad I'm gonna tell you this
though I still feel real fall is going
to be a solid game man I hope all right
Arcane and great developers hopefully
they get past the 60fps thing and get it
ready for lunch I don't know if they can
but they should really try their best
and um but I still think the game's
gonna be solid man
I just
I got my own things with them and it's
not nothing
it's nothing to do with with redfall I
just want to I wanted this 103.
and I need to stop like
condemning everything that's not
Dishonored because I have a bad habit of
doing that because I want Dishonored so
bad if it's not Dishonored I'm like
catch me when it's Dishonored and he's
not doing that but man I just want it so
bad decided it's such a good game it's a
game pass guys go try it out I think you
guys would enjoy this honor I love both
of them and the DLC
it's I just think that
the reason I want redfall to succeed so
bad is because I think if red Falls does
really really well I might see
Dishonored quicker and then you know who
knows maybe
seeing red ball maybe Fred Falls bad
successful they just never make a
disorder they just continue the red
fault franchise that'd be disappointing
but the good thing is death Loop is in
the Dishonored universe
so I think I think we're gonna see
something Dishonored I just don't know
when because to me if they wanted to to
cut off the Dishonored Universe they
never would have made a part of uh death
Loop they could have eased because it
was after the game came out that they
confirmed that so they didn't have to do
none of that they did that because they
want to combine the two I think it would
be cool after you break the loop
if
um
man what's the main character from Death
loop I already forgot his name
I think I think it would be cool if he
joined
corvo and Emily
yeah
oh you know the same universe that's
kind of weird they're in a loop
oh that's right Tom they're in a loop
they've been in a loop for years and
years and years you know that's right
yeah if they get back and corvo's bad
hit like the the power of the outsider
has just warped his mind
and now he's the antagonist
that'd be dumb
yeah it just that's all I want I just
want I want the industry to do better I
want everyone to do better I'm playing
Zelda you know I'm playing Star field
I'm playing Spider-Man this year playing
everything it's scary I'm playing
everything but I'm playing everything
this year Alex
I think that's the next year game
thank you okay yeah I don't know for
some reason it might be this year but I
feel like
we still ain't got the the info when
what Forza is and I feel like they're
probably gonna hold on to hellblade
because they know they can just drop
that at the beginning of next year
what's crazy is I don't know when a vow
is coming out either
it's probably 2024 but you don't know
when in the year though yeah so it's
going to be interesting man it's going
to be interesting you know what I was
thinking we should do
I saw Jeff grob he was doing a Jeopardy
game
it's like
Jeopardy questions that you generate
and then we play the Jeopardy
the questions that maybe the community
generate if we answer them and they put
the points on like we're playing
Jeopardy but some gaming questions
I think you'll be cool I think it'll be
cool if you did that and you put like an
E3 like you're not like the topic so
give me 300 Bill
and so I think it would be cool if you
had a um an E3 topic and it would tell
you a game and you have to guess what E3
was announced at
um
you know obviously not every game was
announced at E3 I know that I know don't
put the comment section I know that but
I think it'll be cool to have something
like that
uh but anyway let's go and start
wrapping this up man let's start
wrapping this up yo first off
we've been uh let me put it in the time
stamps the outro
is one hour
and 29 minutes
all right so
first off I want to appreciate everyone
coming through
you know you guys pulled up like you
always do we had a 400 like three or
four people in here this week you know
first off shout out to to the people
that pulled up in any way shape or form
super chats liking those show first off
like the podcast man let's get those
likes up yeah there's 330 or 340 people
in here we got 116 likes I think we
could do better than that yeah come on
like I realized I didn't like it I just
like that yeah see look man we can't be
telling them to do it you ain't doing it
like what kind of you ain't putting a
good an example man yeah man what kind
of stuff was that dirt try to get better
at promoting it but you know first off
usually at the beginning of the show
every show now we're doing like a
patreon thing where we just ask her some
of the patreon questions because
um YouTube's got a member thing to do
this uh as you can see when I read the
member chats so we're trying to balance
a little bit with the patreon so if you
guys want to go over there we react to
anime uh what's funny is cog's about to
react to to metal music
oh wow because because he thinks Green
Day is metal
oh not listen I even know Green Day is
not metal so we're gonna he's gonna
react to some metal I don't know what
metal yet uh we'll probably let the the
patreon and the members or something uh
get those kind of questions but it's
gonna be interesting you know me and
King we react to a lot of uh anime I
know over there I've I brought solvent
he reacted to some some Demon Slayer so
that's kind of content we're getting
over there you guys go over there it's
uh there's already like I reacted to all
of uh
uh chainsaw man Kings react and Attack
on Titan season two right now he did a
good a couple episodes from season one
because he watched a few of them on his
own uh we're gonna get season two
probably in the next couple weeks we got
I think I have till
next month of content already scheduled
for patreon every week but I'm pretty
sure we're coming through uh dirt where
can the people find you at man I want
you to expand that in the chat because I
know I have to tell you right now yeah I
know you know I'm on my phone it takes
longer to do it that way will you uh you
you spam it once I'll grab it and I'll
spam it through okay yeah spam I just
put it in there
go sub to dirt
yeah like I said guys
um I'm a pro Xbox Channel we talk a lot
of trash uh you know being in this uh
chat today it was kind of weird seeing
so many ponies because we have a pony
free zone over there if you're a pony
you come up in there talking trash now
if you're a pony you wanted this chill
that's fine man you know we do talk a
lot of trash I'm telling you guys but if
you want to come in and say Xbox is dog
[__] Xbox is trash you will get sniped
immediately we might
uh hold up watch your face reacting is
an anime and you mean watching your face
reaction yeah um yeah two anime that
that's what we're doing King's doing it
too everyone's doing it look man we
might have a lot of PlayStation people
in there sometimes they get loose but I
will say for the most part it's not like
like the toxic PlayStation Community
they might go in there and say some Jabs
but I've seen some actual PlayStation
chat and they're they're toxic as [__]
likes so is is as crazy it is sometimes
I will say our chat for the most part is
pretty chill like for the most part
sometimes they get a little crazy but I
will say our chat for the most part is
pretty chill but you know I want to
thank everyone for coming through here
we took like three weeks off uh you know
that's not dirt that was me first week
we went to pack second week I was
recovering from Pax and third week I was
moving so it was just a giant set of
chain stuff it's not generally like that
but I definitely appreciate it for
coming through uh like dirt said go
follow dirt man go follow him on Twitter
go follow him on YouTube there does a
very very good show he's very very extra
and I think a lot of you like the
extra-ness so dirt's the king of it you
know dirt is the king of the actionist
go over there and follow him for that
King The King content because he'd be
doing it he'd be doing it a lot he'd be
doing it good it's like he said man you
know if you want a pony free zone
because he really is only crazy I mean
that bro you need a shirt I just got
like in here named Nix he would have got
sniped so quick in my chat he's been
talking trash the whole podcast it was
you know talking trash is fine but
we need a safe haven away from him bro
you know you need a shirt that says Pony
freeze exactly
I keep on spamming with all these emojis
bro
yeah you know how it is man man but I
will see you this week we're gonna have
our 300th episode of IOP
I'm going to talk to uh dirt about the
the logistics of it afterwards I think
he's gonna do it yeah what we have in
mind uh but I appreciate for coming
through like I said go go check out the
patreon you know become a member if you
want I would say patreon's more
dedicated to r r with you know reactions
and stuff like that we do give you a
tier where every week on any show you
can ask questions if that show is active
that week now if it's not active and if
it's like gaming let's see the attic
Show is canceled this week and a couple
of you asked questions it would be moved
to the IOP questions uh but I appreciate
it for coming through and until next
time this is addict and